hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast a benchtop platform for
massively parallel CRISPR based
microbial genome engineering presented
by dr. Daniel health director
applications development add-in scripta
I'm Christy jewel of laberd's and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminars brought
to you by lab roots and sponsored by in
scripta for more information on our
sponsor please click on the inscription
logo at the left side of your screen or
go to in script s com
now let's get started I would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click assign button we will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab down at the top right of the
presentation window or you can use that
ask a question box to let us know you're
experiencing a problem I would now like
to introduce to you our speaker dr.
Daniel health dr. health has worked in
molecular biology directed evolution and
strain engineering in a variety of
industrial microbes for the last 12
years he is a director of synthetic
biology within the microbial
applications development group for a
complete biography on dr. held please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
dr. held you may now begin your
presentation
great Thank You Christy for that nice
introduction I'm Dan health I'll be your
presenter today and it's my pleasure to
be able to be here to talk to you about
in script as onyx platform which is a
new benchtop platform for massively
parallel CRISPR based microbial genome
engineering and there's a lot to unpack
just from that title alone so what I'd
like to do over the course of the
presentation is break that up into three
parts I like to provide an overview of
the underlying technology and then move
into an example workflow on the onyx
platform to give you a feel for what the
customer will experience using the
platform and then finally walk through a
sample data set that we've generated at
in scripta in the applications
development team to really begin to
generate datasets with these libraries
much in line with what what we believe
and anticipate the customers will do
themselves and generate and share with
you what that dataset looks like and how
a customer might go about analyzing the
data so to start this is a CRISPR based
platform and so while CRISPR is
certainly here to stay and most folks
are familiar with with the basic premise
by now I did want to level says so the
technology with a brief review of CRISPR
based genome editing and so what I'm
showing here is a simplified overview of
a CRISPR nucleus could be a caste 9
could be a caste 12 that part isn't as
important as the general concept of the
editing although I will remind the
listener that in scripta supporting a
CRISPR nucleus called mat 7 which we
released publicly just over two years
ago and that sequence is still available
on our website for download if a
customer is interested and that is also
the exact same nuclease that will run on
the onyx platform so just keep that in
mind as I go but in principle the CRISPR
again workflow is the same regardless of
the nucleus you're using and that is the
enzyme loads with a guide RNA which then
will target the nucleus to the
appropriate location in the genome to
impart a double-stranded break but again
cast 9 that will be a blunt ended
cleavage event and format 7 in a cast 12
family
that'll be a sticky end break but the
point remains once that targeted double
strand cleavage event occurs there's
basically three possible outcomes only
two of which are relevant to genome
engineering the first is simply cell
death and that is a double strand break
is a lethal event and so if the cell is
unable to repair that double strand
break there's no editing and there's
there's no follow-on to the story but
really in terms of how the cell would go
about repairing that double strand break
takes us to the editing story and so one
option is a non hollom non-homologous
end joining repair or the double strand
break is repaired either the wild-type
sequence being restored or an in dell is
made and oftentimes the in dell is what
imparts the subsequent phenotype most
often times inactivation of that gene by
introduction of a downstream premature
stop codon on the gene and that's not
where the scripted technology goes we're
really more interested in employing the
homology directed for repair and that's
where a donor DNA sequence is provided
that imparts a very specific and precise
edit as desired by the customer to the
cut site and so in fact for the rest of
the presentation just bear in mind that
everything we're talking about and all
the editing that's run on the Onix
platform runs through an HDR type repair
and in doing so the edits that are made
are going to be very precise and user
directed and so I want to right away
even before I get into anything more
about the platform emphasize that point
one more time and to show the listener
the types of edits that we've already
been making using this technology and so
you can see we're editing both non
coding and coding regions of the genome
non-coding on the left
we've been editing with 60 base pair
promoter insertions in e.coli just
upstream of the start codon on open
reading frames all around the genome and
as well in yeast we have an example of
making terminator substitutions of about
35 to 40 base pairs so these are again
very precise and specified edits that
the customer will be able to make using
the platform and then certainly within
the coding region of genes
user can insert a premature stop codon
and we've taken to inserting a triple
stop insert which is a nine base pair
insertion give a 5 prime end of genes to
impart that premature stop codon and
knock out protein function and certainly
within a gene the user can be organized
at the codon level site saturation
mutagenesis
and edits of that type so there's one
other really important sort of
foundational aspect to editing with the
Onix platform and that is the physical
joining of the guide and donor DNA
sequences so in a typical addressed
build where the guide and donor DNA's
are Co transformed into the cell and
editing results as a function of that
nucleus directed cut and donor directed
repair this will scale to the degree
that a user or researcher has the
capacity to design and and build as many
of these sort of code transformants as
desired but the key component to this
workflow is that each of those builds is
compartmentalized separately and again
so that will scale to the degree that
the user has automation or time or or
brute force to build as many of these
design designs as they like again code
transformation requires that every
strand be built separately but that only
scales to so many hundreds or maybe
thousands of strains over time and so
really if you want to scale up into
thousands or tens of thousands of
designs and this is the direction that
it's scripted has taken the technology
that is to move to a pooled build
scenario and the pooled build approach
breaks down rapidly as a function of
Coach chance formation because the
likelihood that the appropriate guide
and donor pair will find one another and
be Co transformed into the same cell is
a function that's inversely inversely
proportional to the number of pairs in
the population and so whereas a small
frequency of the Transformus will indeed
receive the appropriate guide donor pair
to cut and repair and part the edit the
rest of the population most likely will
be transformed with a cutting guide but
not too appropriate
donar to make the repair and so a large
fraction of population basically drops
out drops away and this is a difficult
paradigm to build a lot of high number
of novel strains and so really the key
insight and technical advance that was
made by one of our founders Andrew Garst
was to physically join the guides and
the donors together onto the same DNA
molecule and so now in a pooled build
paradigm those thousands of designs can
be transformed simultaneously every
transform it is by definition code
transformed with the appropriate go
diner guide donor pair because they're
linked physically and now the build
becomes much more scalable and you
really can now reach this massively
parallel strain engineering concept that
the onyx platform enables
and reiterate that one more time in
terms of what what it you know really
looks like in the lab the addressable
build is basically done in 96 well or
384 well plates where the guide and
donor code transformed as separate
molecules and the tracking is done at
the level of the per well or the per
plate sample via bar coding and liquid
handling and automation of that sort but
in the pooled paradigm the cell now
becomes the partition and now with
hundreds of thousands of cells in the
population at the moment of
transformation they become the
partitions themselves the guide and
donor are provided as part of the same
molecule as well as now a trackable
barcode and so that tracking is now
performed at the level of the cell
is sort of the foundational nature of
the technology let's talk a little bit
about where that takes us in the strain
engineering space historically if you
think about string engineering as an
exercise that really is caught in a
balance between the number of genomic
locations that the investigator desires
editing on and the types of edits that
the investigator would love to impart on
those genomes we've really if you map
that into a two-dimensional space with
locations on the x axis and variety that
it types on the on the y axis on this
diagram we've really historically been
restricted to either of the two axes and
it's been very challenging to get into
that upper right quadrant and so I
explained that briefly if you think
about classical mutagenesis obviously
that's the flavor of strain engineering
that's been around for the longest not
terribly well controlled but the full
genome is certainly in play the user
doesn't really have the ability to
control where the mutations go in how
many mutations go in simultaneously
nor the type of mutations that are
imparted it's an imperfect albeit
fruitful way to proceed and likewise
investigators can make a genome-wide
knockout collection mchale collection
has been fantastic resource free coli
researchers but that was a painstaking
build and really again the edit type
you're limited to that that knockout on
each each gene in the genome whereas if
we switch to the vertical axis most
typically whether an investigator wants
to work on a native gene or a native
pathway or even a series of heterologous
genes you're really restricted to just a
a small number of locations on the
genome although they're the Edit variety
is greater because an investigator even
if using a CRISPR based approach to
reuse the same guide RNA and and co
deliver different donor sequences that
might enable protein engineering or
promoter tweaks or signal peptide tweaks
again depending on the nature of of the
editing that the the user is trying to
achieve but in both cases that
upper-right quadrant
having a large number of locations
around the genome accessible as well as
a broad number of edit types available
on all of those locations has been the
challenge and that's really what we
added scripta
to enable and and with the onyx platform
we will be able to enable genome wide
engineering as well as genome discovery
and that's what the onyx platform will
deliver both the combination of
unprecedented scale around the genome
superior performance and greater access
both to the genome and to technology
because this will be available to any
customer working on the onyx platform
so now if we start to step into what a
workflow would look like for a user with
the onyx platform I'd like to hang that
on to the design generate test learn
cycle really to call out the fact that
the generate the ability to build large
amounts of strain diversity has has
really been the bottleneck in this
workflow historically and so while the
design and the learn side of the
workflow are more an informatics
capability we're really not in any way
practically limited to the number of
designs an investigator can can dream up
informatica li and certainly our ability
to do deep sequence analysis is now here
on the learn side and so when it comes
to building strains or generating the
type of diversity that that could feed
this design get generate tests learn
cycle with a skilled team of molecular
violet biologists or strain engineers
working in the lab really the number of
strains that those individuals or teams
can turn around on a per week cadence is
limited in some degree to the to the
organism that you're working in but also
to the types of engineering that you're
trying to achieve to really single-digit
or maybe low double-digit numbers of
strains per week and then improve
somewhat with the introduction of
automation
again this addressable build in 96-well
plates the throughput certainly goes up
into the tens hundreds and even low
thousands of strains per week but really
there's the remains of impedance
mismatch with the rest of the cycle
particularly when the test side can
screen hundreds to thousands of strains
per week either again using robotic
automation or a flow cytometry or pool
based selections and so finally what the
onyx platform will do will further push
the boundary of what the user can build
on the instrument on the onyx platform
in a single build the low end offering
for an scripted library will be 100
designs and the high entry coli will be
10,000 designs per library or
6,000 designs in yeast so now we're
really pushing up the build rate that a
user can concern through this design
generate test learn or flow okay so the
onyx platform it will consist of an
instrument software and reagents and so
let me talk about what that means
exactly from the user experience again
I'll walk through the use of instrument
software and reagents as they're mapped
back to the design generate test and
learn workflow but a little startling
design side within script is easy to use
web portal for designing and ordering
the strain engineering libraries and
then once library is received as
consumable kit reagents those will go on
to the instrument for the for the
automated editing run cells come off the
instrument at the end of editing and the
customer will really run test in a
couple of parts one will be a genotyping
side testing the performance of the
library as well as identifying the
sequences of any hit or interesting
strains that come out of the test but
the test workflow itself is really in
the customers hands and I'll I'll dive
into that a little bit more deeply in
subsequent slides and then of course
this will all feed back under the learn
portion of the cycle which is pairing of
the genotyping and phenotyping
information that will be obtained from
the test side so let me walk through
that a little bit more detail in the
next few slides okay so the design in
the customer portable the customer will
define their host strain again the Onix
will support strain engineering and East
in e.coli
sacra my sister lúcia that is Andy
colitis stars the user will select which
targets within the genome they want to
make edits on and design the Edit
libraries and then will be able to order
reagents right through the web portal
through the shopping cart function and
really again to really drive the point
home or offering is precision variety
and scale so what that means is in
sacrum Isis or e.coli the host user will
define their genome whether it's a
custom genome or basic wild-type genome
specify the Edit types right now
insertions deletions and substitutions
are all available both in coding and
non-coding regions of the genome with a
current size of up to sixty base pairs
adjacent and from within these options
the user can really now start to get
into the Edit strategy they want to take
as an engineer their genome so whether
it's all within orph editing on genes as
shown in the top diagram there or in
regulatory regions of genes or some
combination of both this really should
allow the user to either pursue specific
hypotheses or remain totally agnostic
and design
Discovery type libraries where it's
really a hypothesis
building strategy and then ultimately
again the full genome is in is in place
so as long as there's a Pam within
proximity to the region that the
investigator would like to edit those
designs can be made in the software and
under the hood the software really is
driven by some robust and powerful
algorithms that have been trained now
for the last couple of years a 10 script
and general features include having been
trained on over 300,000 designed so far
thousands of features
evaluated and we've created over 200
excuse me 2 million designs in total to
test and feature improvement is ongoing
and this would include a really deep
characterization of
of PAM recognition by mad seven as well
as understanding how to best immunize
the edited region against subsequent
recutting by mad seven maximizing
designs for cut to edit edit distance as
well as donor DNA lathe and many more so
these features are all built into the
design software as a customer specifies
where they want to edit their genome and
what what edits they want to make to
really to really drive superior
performance of the editing outcome so
once the customer pushes go in the
shopping cart there's about a three week
turnaround time for those reagents to be
manufactured at in scripta and then the
customer will receive in the mail their
editing kit components and that'll
include all the consumables that the
user will load onto the deck of the
instrument and be able to push go and
then walk away and allow the instrument
to handle all the wet lab manipulations
that are part of the editing process and
at the other end of the editing runs
it'll be a two-day run for the coli
libraries and a three-day run for yeast
libraries the output file is a single
vial mixed population of cells which
collectively will contain all of the
edits in that library which the user is
then free to now move into their
phenotyping or their test workflows and
so the test workflow really becomes
pretty complex in part because at this
point it's very much in users hands in
terms of how they want to handle the
cells both from the very most immediate
manipulation of running edit QC to
really understand library performance
and then more more meaningfully for the
research program moving into their
phenotyping and again this this is a
space that's wide open according to what
the customer has specified for their
edit library and how exactly they want
to screen that population to begin to
look at phenotype and then again there's
another sequencing component to the
genotyping side because the barcodes can
be tracked and the Edit speed can be
confirmed on the genome descriptor will
provide sequencing kits as well to
support Sanger based and ingest based
workflow
as a customer both QC is the library and
evaluates kick variance
so I want to step for a moment into how
in scripted calls edits on the platform
because it turns out that not every
edits will be complete nor intended and
those are terms that we at inscripted
have taken to use to talk to our
customers about edits made using the
technology so let me explain what that
means a little bit so that the script
editor is strictly defined as complete
which means it includes all the design
changes at the nucleotide level and
intended and that those changes exact
exactly match the original design so if
you look at this simplistic sequence
alignment on the right where the
wild-type sequence is at the top the
design that it would be a triplet a
codon triplet change at the target codon
encoding for a threonine excuse me a
tyrosine that we want to minute mutate
to three and eight so you can see the
three nucleotides are changed there and
then just downstream is the pam sequence
that has been edited to immunize against
further cutting and those two edits are
made in the Wobble positions of the next
to downstream codons so that that final
protein product will really only carry
at the amino acid level the targeted
change can still maintain or preserve
the wild-type sequence at the next two
codons even though it's a DNA level
they've now been edited okay again
immunize against at seven recutting
so the complete intended at it looks
exactly like it designed at it and
that's what in fact most of what the
customer will get in their population
but there is a subpopulation of cells
that will be for all intensive purposes
received a complete edit so in this case
only the Wobble position mismatches with
the design and fortuitously it still
encodes a threonine at that codon but
it's not the precise we intended add
edges so that one wouldn't get called as
an edit by the inscript of analysis
software
even though functionally it is a dia
variant in the population and one which
the customer may very well be happy with
at the phenotype level and then beyond
that there's another option a sub
component of the population where the
edit has
was made but only partially or
incompletely and in this case and this
is most often the way it plays out the
auxilary edit was made to immunize
against recutting but for some reason
the target at it was not made and most
often this will occur where the cut to
edit distance is much greater than I've
shown in this simplistic example and
where the repair you get across an event
with the donor template that basically
leaves out the target edit while
immunizing against tree cutting so that
again represents a subpopulation that
comes off of the onyx instrument but
that's not counted in the formal edit
count
and to dive a little bit deeper into the
into the types of performance metrics
that we're currently talking about with
customers the four big ones are edit
efficiency which has just just described
so as the fraction of cells within the
population with complete and intended
edits and that basically is assessed at
the genomic level we're not tracking
barcodes for that because we truly want
to know who's edited and then the next
three metrics basically are derived from
the barcode tracking and that basically
looks at the coverage of the library how
many of the designs are observed in the
edit population and what's the
distribution of those edits across the
population obviously a tighter CV means
a more equal distribution of the edit
types but we we do admit and anyone
who's built a library has observed
population skew which is sometimes a
function of the genes being targeted for
editing
sometimes a function of the mixture of
edits within the population themselves
so this is a level of analysis that's
going to be important to every user but
will need to be assessed on an
individual library basis and on the
right I'm just showing examples of edit
efficiencies that we've achieved that
inscripted with the technology in both
used in e.coli with building libraries
of various sizes so from about a hundred
designs all the way up to ten thousand
in e.coli and a hundred up to just over
eight thousand and yeast although I
should note that these are developmental
libraries and the upper limit for yeast
libraries at time of first customership
later this year will be a bus will be
capped at 6,000 designs but nevertheless
it gives you a feel for a range of about
a thirty to thirty to seventy percent
edit efficiency across different
libraries in both organisms and
different library designs
okay so the other part of test that was
just the genotyping side pre-screen
obviously the customer wants to have
once they have this rich library the
thousands of designs well-edited wants
to begin to test the population and find
hits and interesting variants and so
what I've drawn out over the next two
slides are a couple of examples of
customer driven phenotyping workflows
and we can imagine that the onyx
platform will be of great value of
customers who already have a
high-throughput automated screening
capability in place and I would involve
automated colony picking I'm showing the
molecular devices cubics here 96 well or
384 well plate liquid handling
automation high-throughput shaking 4 to
grow those populations and then
ultimately some sort of high throughput
phenotyping tool in the backend whether
it's plate readers mass spec as shown
here this is basically a workflow for a
user who will want to phenotype
libraries at the individual strain level
but the other end of the spectrum will
be users who either don't have that type
of screening infrastructure in place or
maybe don't even necessarily have a
research program that requires that type
of screening and really it's the
population dynamics that are of interest
customer could simply take that
population of pooled cells that come off
of the Onyx and maintain maintain the
cells in population either in shake
flasks or some other pooled cultivation
format and proceed right through the DNA
sequencing of the barcodes at the end of
the experiment and so I I put together
these two slides really just to call out
the extreme differences in those two
workflows and to acknowledge that the
customer can do those two things and
everything in between and potentially
even screening workflows that we haven't
imagined yet but in principle V onyx
platforms ability to generate a
high-quality library can be passed
through any of those workflows should
remain the same high value any of those
customers
and ultimately then the seeds back into
the learned portion of the design
generate tests learn workflow and that
is by whatever means the customer
chooses to screen their populations and
collect the phenotyping data that will
need to be mapped back to the genome
iving strains or populations and this is
really where the learn capability again
this will be another portion of the
descriptive web portal to which a
customer can join those data and take
advantage of a variety of tools that
will allow them to learn from those
experiments and the potentially move
into the next cycle of design generate
test learn and design and build new
libraries derived from that first round
whether it is combinatorial mutagenesis
or strain improvement or just tweaking
some hypotheses and making new edits
that hadn't been part of the first
population
okay so hopefully that gives you a sense
of what the workflow looks like on the
onyx platform and then really allows us
to step in to starting to think about
the application space and and really it
is an open frontier every alluded to
that in terms of the types of screening
workflows the customer might use but
that doesn't even speak to the types of
libraries a customer might consider
building and then moving through those
various you know typing workflows so
really that space is wide open and
within the applications development team
in its scripta we spent time running
both internal projects to try to
generate sample data sets that would
speak to users with various applications
in mind as well as partner with early
access kol x' to run the technology for
them for their projects to begin to
generate data they could go talk about
and that we could all learn from
collectively and so I want to now spend
on the last portion of the presentation
walking you through one of those
applications that we've run internally
and that is this osmotic stress response
in e.coli and so the workflow
essentially looks like this where the
designs were the libraries were designed
to generated using in scripts of
Technology and the engineered
populations of cells were kept pooled
we ran growth selections in shake flasks
and and then went directly to barcode
amplicon sequencing to generate count
data on those barcodes to look for
enrichment and depletion within the
population as a function of the response
to the assault stress and really we now
move into the analysis and learn portion
of that project and so I'll walk you
through the what the data looks like and
how we chosen to analyze it and you also
get a flavor from this workflow the time
scale on which a user could execute this
type of project given the various
different steps okay so to set the stage
with the types of libraries that went
into this experiment here we're working
in e.coli and we wanted to target in a
somewhat agnostic way really know no
primary hypothesis behind this
experiment but a true discovery
experiment target all of the known genes
ecoli so just over 4,000 total annotated
genes and we made seven possible edit
types on every one of those loci either
insertion of one of five different
promoters of varying strains or two
knockouts on each of those genes one at
codon position five and the other at
codon shift position 15 again near the
five prime end of the gene so as to
impart that premature stop codon and
functionally knockout protein expression
so in total we were able to design about
25,000 of the just over 28,000 total
designs that we desired and you can see
I've got a reminder on the bottom left
of the types of what the promoter
insertions look like as well as the
triple stop and the promoters if you're
not familiar with this particular
promoter set they're available on the
IgM website and these are promoters that
have been used in many of the IgM
constant competitions over the years and
they've been characterized in a number
of different ways but originally they
were characterized for their relative
strength expression of the red
fluorescent protein these are just small
synthetic constitutive promoters so the
weakest of which was set with a
strengths of relative strengths of one
and then the other four promoters you
can see have increasing strains relative
to that weaker of the promoters so these
seven libraries were all built
separately and then those populations
were pooled and used starting inoculum
for the shape classic experiments and
you can see at the 48 hour endpoint of
the experiment we did achieve saturated
growth in our shake flasks I should
remind everyone this was an m9 middle
supplemented m9 minimal media with
glucose as the sole carbon source and
then a sodium chloride titration either
no salt or 2060 or 200 millimolar sodium
chloride and twelve flasks in total
those four conditions shown there and
three replicate flasks on each condition
and so once the barcode amplicon
sequencing is completed we have a very
large and rich data set from which the
user can begin to start to mine for
discovery stories of this an experiment
of this kind and so I'm showing on the
left the normalized barcode counts by
sample there's 25 rows in the state of
excuse me 25,000 rows in this data table
corresponding to the 25,000 design able
edits and you can see the two columns
for the edit that was made one of the
five promoters or a knockout at
positions 5 or 15 and then the
particulars enon which that edit was
made and then 12 more columns which
correspond to the data coming from each
of the 12 shaped flasks again the for
salt treatments by 3 replicates for each
condition and so in total this results
in a table of 300,000 data points which
we can now begin to derive some
interesting information and the first
way that we went about analyzing that
data set was to simply look at a
population distribution as a function of
the 12 samples the the sodium chloride
treatments and you can see by PCA
analysis that the no salt and Lois salts
samples cluster near one another and
that you begin to achieve some
separation as you move into your salt
titration of higher concentrations so
right there at the most high level
global view you can see the data already
begins to look interesting but if we go
from that most low resolution view to
the highest possible resolution view and
zoom all the way into that blown blade
of grass in the meadow we pulled out
here the waz gene in e.coli which is
involved in lipopolysaccharide core
biosynthesis and what we're showing now
is one row of our 25,000 rows in that
table and the one particular well at the
12 particular columns that correspond to
the 1 edit in this case the medium
strength promoter made on waaz and so
now you can see that the counts begin to
change the amplicon excuse me the
barcode counts from the amplicon data
begin to increase for that particular
edit as a function of increasing salt
concentration suggesting that strains in
which that edit was made indeed have a
growth advantage in the population and
so if we derive a slope from those data
points we can now assign that slope to
every single one of the rows in that
data table as the biological response of
that edit to this particular treatment
condition if we stay on that locus but
zoom out just a little bit now we can
look at all seven edits together to edit
from the previous slide is boxed in the
middle in purple and the other six edits
are now shown you can see instantly a
very interesting pattern begin to emerge
or all five of the promoter edits confer
a beneficial benefit to the growth of
those strains in the pooled population
of varying degrees whereas the knockouts
were absolutely detrimental and those
strains are depleting from the
population with an increase in salt dose
and so now if with that slope that's
been assigned to all of those data
points per row in the data table we can
now zoom out one more level and now plot
all 25,000 rows as a data point which is
that slope that we're calling the
biological response and the waaz
data that was shown on the previous
slides is shown as the purple points to
give you a frame of reference for how
that particular gene is behaving in the
population but within every column this
4,000 other points representing all the
rest of the coli genome and those seven
edits having been made at every other
locus around the genome and so now a
very rich data set but the investigator
can really begin to dive into and start
to understand what's happening either at
the population level or single gene
level
so if we zoom out one more time and run
another PCA analysis this time not by
treatment or sodium chloride
concentration but by edit type another
couple of interesting patterns emerge
and on the left side if we look at all
seven edit types together you can see
the two knockouts which are the two
black balls on the bottom of the the
diagram are separating from the five
promoter edits and if the same analysis
is run but withholding the knockouts
even within the promoter population you
see this interesting topology appears to
be somewhat of a corkscrew or spiral
that moves from lowest to strongest a
promoter strain so another interesting
component to the data that that strange
twist seems to be a reproducible
phenotype on those promoter edits even
across different selection schemes that
we've run so we don't fully understand
it at the moment but a meaningful signal
that that's certainly warrants deeper
investigation and then one more way to
analyze the population is not by
treatment type or by edit type but now
by gene performance and gene clustering
and so we've chosen to run some you map
clustering on these populations which
which is analysis method that's become
common in the single cell sequencing
field and here what you can do is zoom
in on a number of different clusters and
start to see what the biological slope
or the biological response looks like
across the members of genes that are in
that cluster so in the first example
shown the molesting orange you see a
pattern of uniform depletion meaning no
matter what the Edit was knock out or
any of the five promoters upon treatment
with increasing sodium chloride these
edits were uniformly deleterious and
these members were depleting from the
population and some go term analysis
reveals something that maybe isn't
surprising we've hit on genes that tend
to be involved in sent core metabolic
processes
so you see DNA replication protein
synthesis carbon metabolism probably
regions of the genome that are that are
particularly sensitive to editing and
again are depleting in the presence
of the rest of the population in this
experiment on the other side of the map
you can see a fairly large cluster with
a response profile that looks very much
like when I Chum previously for the waaz
locus and in fact that those edits are
included in this population where the
knockout was depleting but the five
promoter edits are enriching in the
population can't go term analysis there
reveals genes that are involved in
membrane integrity or generalized cell
stress responses again maybe not
surprising resistance profile among
those cells and then a couple more to
flesh out the set on the lower left you
can see almost the opposite profile
where the knockouts for whatever reason
biology biologically are enriched but
promoter edits are depleting and finally
this large group on the lower right all
edits seem to be enriching so again
another way to begin to parse the data
and dive into what hopefully will become
very interesting stories for the for the
biologists interested in discovery
so we stay in one of those go term
groups in this in this case the cellular
response to osmotic stress and we map
genes in that category back to their
physiological role in e.coli you can see
that edits
that we're enriching are called out in
and maroon and edits that were depleting
or called out in orange and so these
genes are all involved in again survey
response to osmotic stress so if nothing
else these should be validating edits
that this technology should be able to
find technology should be able to find
and if we zoom in on a couple of
examples this G a G SH a gene is is one
of two enzymes involved in conversion of
glutamate to glutathione which is an
important intracellular ozma light that
the cell uses to regulate its its
osmolarity in the context of changing
environmental conditions a knock out on
this gene is depleting in the population
so no surprise there and that's actually
confirmed in the literature and
conversely this pro-x which is the
membrane
see any protein involved in the uptake
of glycine beta in another important
osmolytes
here the middle strength promoter again
is conferred but enriching a phenotype
for these strains of the population and
again this is confirmed in literature as
well so in this case we've called out
variants that can be confirmed that are
validating as a function of what's known
in literature but within that same
cluster on the you map profile our other
genes behaving similarly for which
perhaps there's been no prior annotation
at all or even functional annotation
that is or even prior association with a
phenotypic response to osmotic stress so
this is where hopefully the doors are
opening now for discovery for the user
it's a one final slide I'm down to the
last few slides now one final slide to
basically flip the story on on that
particular project because I told the
story there from the context of an
investigator who really wants to
discover and perhaps understand biology
the response to particular genes
genome-wide in e.coli to a sodium
chloride challenge but I'd like to
propose that that an investigator could
design the exact same design and build
the exact same libraries and run the
exact same phenotyping experiment for a
totally different purpose in this case
it would be for a forward engineering
application where perhaps now you're a
bio industrial user who's interested in
strain engineering to improve growth of
your particular particular production
strain in production tanks and may be
growth is stalling out during the later
portions of fermentation as a function
of buildup of unwanted secondary
metabolites it in the media the same
enriched genes that we would have
analyzed in the last couple of slides to
understand their biological importance
now become fodder or candidates for
subsequent rounds of combinatorial
engineering where each of those
mutations are individually beneficial to
cell survival the presence of increasing
salt that can now begin to
combined together to further improve
that strain performance in the context
again of whatever the industrial
application might be so the point there
is simply that the onyx platform should
service users regardless of their
primary research goal and we're very
excited to be able to tell that story
and present this product for researchers
across the board and so that brings me
to the last slide and I just like to
summarize the onyx CRISPR base to
microbial engineering platform is here
and it's going to deliver user-friendly
workflow for rapid dgq cycles for the
customer genome scale intervention and
mapping of genotype to phenotype
relationships is now possible and really
what that means is we're moving genome
biology from one of correlation to one
of true causation where the Edit is made
the phenotype can be directly measured
and you can now begin to understand the
cause of the function of that gene or
those edits made on that gene or region
of the genome so ultimately this should
allow the investigator to focus their
expertise and resources and pursuit of
the most important research questions
and the goals and not be hung up trying
to build these libraries or build their
strains really just use onyx to build
the populations for you and move into
your into your research program and with
that I'd like to say thank you I'm happy
to field any questions
dr. help thank you for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar now to our
audience if you have any questions you
would like to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for okay
let's get started with so many questions
already coming in after help let's start
with this one what is the maximum size
in base pair length for edits
that's right so currently at first
customership will be supporting edits of
up to 60 base pairs in size and so just
to be specific about that the customer
can make an edit of a single nucleotide
single snip and any combination of base
pairs all the way up to 16 nucleotides
for both insertions deletions and
substitutions
held our next question do you have any
plans to scale edit sizes up to ten
kilobases that's a great one and we do
get that one very frequently at first
customership the answer is that won't be
offered on the instrument but it's
definitely on our roadmap although I
shouldn't at this point it's not exactly
clear when that offering will come
available but we know that something
customers want and that's definitely
part of what we're developing right now
very good our next question are each of
the edits clonal great question that's
right so when that population of cells
comes off the Onyx instrument every
individual cell in the population is at
that point by definition clonal and so
once those cells are plated if the user
chooses to do that those colonies that
would come off of an auger plate are
indeed clonal at that point as well as
any cells that would grow up within the
population would derive from a clonal
founder
what's the molecular nature of the G RNA
DNA donor pair is it plasmid linear DNA
etc great question that's right um yeah
from the diagrams in the deck you can't
pick that up but in both used to be coli
those DNA's are paired on a plasmid
very good with so many questions coming
in alright let's go with this one um I
think what is the workflow for pool the
barcode screen without a growth
selection based readout
you
I understand that one right let me just
try to restate it a pooled barcode read
without a selection is that what the
question read
it's written what is the work for Ibis
our pardon me workflow for a pooled
barcode screen without a growth
selection based readout yeah that's an
interesting one I might encourage the
listener who asked that question too
maybe submit I'll answered as well as I
can right now live but if I don't hate
it exactly maybe resubmit some more
fleshed-out version to be sure I'm
understanding but basically the
population of cells to get to the
barcode amplicon data the population of
cells is basically lysed
in mass and the DNA plasmid DNA is
isolated and then typically run an NGS
sequencing run on the plasmid population
and do about barcode mapping back to the
Edit designs and count those edits as a
function of the number of barcodes in
the population so I don't feel like I
exactly hit the answer right so please
resubmit that if you'd like a more
nuanced answer and I'm happy to answer
it online or by email
carry good doctor health could I give
you an already edited strain to generate
a library from it
that's a great question and in fact
that's at first customership the user
will have the opportunity to edit either
on Ecole IMG 1655 so-called wild-type or
BL 21 and in yeast on s 288 C or cent DK
and any of those four strains unmodified
would be supplied with the editing kit
by an scripta but we understand that
most users will probably have their own
custom strains that are derived from any
of those four strains in which they've
already made previous manipulations and
those strains are indeed editable poly
onyx platform and a customer we're able
to add those strains to their
consumables kit once those arrive and
then I will have full instructions for
how a customer we put their own strains
onto the instrument for that editing
thank you
let's see next one does genotyping
clarify that only one edit has been made
per cell that's right so there's a
couple of different modes by which the
customer will be able to genotype
their their strains and in a coma mode
typically the sequencing approaches will
be looking at the G DNA sequences right
now the first offering on the Onix
specifies a single edit per cell
combinatorial will follow at a later
release later this calendar year so in
that genotyping exercise the user should
be able to confirm single added per
strain and then the population of edits
would be delivered singly across all of
the population of cells in the output
file
you
you are you planning to adapt the otic
system to prime editing that is a great
question and as of right now the onyx
system as released will not incorporate
prime editing or anything comparable but
but prime editing certainly being the
big splash that it is is on our radar
and on our roadmap for development but I
probably can't commit to a more
definitive answer than that right now
it's still developmental
your help
the platform allow for combinatorial
edit
yes the short answer is yes and again
the first shipment will just be a single
will support single editing kids but
within a few months following first
customers using the Onix for single
editing we will be selling and shipping
combinatorial edit kits the customers
can use to then begin to hopefully build
up the wonderful diversity that they've
obtained in their first rounds of single
editing so yes combin
will come to the Onix shortly after
first product release thank you and can
we put other genome rather than equal I
add yeast
yeah we get this one all the time so as
far as the onyx platform that's a
microbial engineering platform and so
over time we would like to add more and
more species to the platform and right
now that species list isn't exactly
finalized but we're working with
customers potential customers and early
access partners to really understand
what the market is asking for so
certainly anyone listening today that is
market information that we're keenly
interested in as we prioritize which
additional species will come to the onyx
platform and then I should say just so
everyone knows the onyx platform is and
will remain a microbe editing platform
but in scripted we'll be launching a
mammalian platform a couple of years
down the road as well thank you Josh are
Heldman we have so many great questions
coming in and we have time for a few
more but I do want to remind our
audience that those questions we are
unable to answer today and those that
come in during the on-demand period they
will be addressed by a doctor health via
the email address you provide at the
time of registration so let's spin a
couple did in a couple more um what does
the Onyx platform do exactly does it
prepare the DNA prepare the competent
shell transform myself did you share
yeah maybe I may be a little bit cagey
on the answer there because some of
exactly what happens on the platform is
part of the proprietary nature the
offering but certainly when the customer
sees the consumable kid it will include
all the reagents buffers media and
transforming DNA so the instrument will
handle all of the wet lab manipulations
basically as asked in the question so
cell growth transformation and then
basically handling of the cells as they
recover from the editing process really
to ensure that the highest quality
outcome that otherwise is difficult to
achieve with a by hand protocol
thank you how do you prevent WT non cut
cells from overtaking population after
transformation yep that is a great
question this obviously comes from a
user who has some experience with these
types of workflows and that's a
challenge frankly that that is the first
part of the answer but that is part of
the micro fluidics features of the Onix
platform that really control for
enrichment and representation of the
edited population in the presence of
that sort of wild type population that
might otherwise try to overrun the
population so I can't dive into the
details of how that's accomplished but
that's absolutely a component of what
the onyx platform does for the user
- held what was designing a kit for a
new microbial species entail
that's a great one unfortunately I
probably you know in this context is
probably just not time to dive into that
so certainly I could potentially respond
to that email online but the truth is
some of that is going to depend a little
bit on what those next organisms are
that are going to come to the onyx
platform so I'm asked to leave it at
that for the purposes of the webinar
Thank You Jerrod and we'll wrap with
this final question will in script the
provide a service run the library
generation for customers to avoid
customers having to purchase an
instrument which may not be fully
utilized in their own lab yeah that
that's a great question
right now the the plan for
commercializing the technology is
through the onyx platform itself so we
are not planning to offer sort of either
pre-made libraries or custom design
libraries that we would build as a
service function so hopefully for a user
that maybe you know has been in mind the
plan would be to run an editing on on
instrument so perhaps there's a core
facility or someone they can partner
with to get access to an onyx instrument
if it's really that isn't going to be a
purchase they want to make themselves
thank you doctor held for this
informative Q&A and I also want to thank
our audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions we had
quite a few questions we were unable to
answer but those will be answered via
the email address you provided at your
time of registration I would once again
like to thank dr. Daniel help for his
time today and as important research I'd
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor in scripta for underwriting
today's educational webcast
webcast can be viewed on to thank you
Dan and this webcast can be viewed on
demand and laboratory our audience via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and we hope to see you all again soon
until next time have a great day